abbiamo un problema
siamo cresciuti in un mondo convinti che
fosse definitivo e quindi quando le cose
cominciano a cambiare
subentra la paura e il fatto che nessuno
può fare previsioni su quello che
succederà quindi forse è il momento di
fare una mappa e capire da dove veniamo
e dove andiamo cercando di capirlo in
modo non pregiudiziale non fissandoci su
gli ancoraggi eravam ancorato in questo
mondo due frasi che tutti quanti abbiamo
girato almeno sette volte nella vita una
e di paul valéry ed è del 1850 circa il
futuro non è più quello di una volta poi
è stato usato come epigrafe in alcuni
romanzi di fantascienza e così all'altra
hai voglia l'abbiamo citata anche molte
più volte ho visto cos'è voi umani non
potreste immaginarvi umani è molto
italiano nell'originale people
semplicemente poi persone comunque oggi
potremmo ancora dire queste frasi
forse non tanto una è quella mi
basterebbe che il futuro non è più
non dimentichiamo che in questo momento
nessuno parla del domani
se non in modo spaventato quando ero
ragazzino io un bel po di anni fa il
futuro era una cosa da immaginare
indefinitamente
adesso un po mi sembra di percepire ci
sia una specie di angoscia permanente il
futuro è chissà dove andremo a finire
chissà come staremo e quindi è questa
un altro aspetto forte anche sulla frase
di philip dick che stava in blade runner
e io direi al contrario ho visto umani
che voi cosa non potreste immaginare
sono degli umani che sono diventati
strani nel senso che siamo diventati
tutti in qualche modo me compreso è
molto imprevedibile allora forse il
momento di cominciare a fare un po una
mappa e questo è il mondo al quale c'è
ancora chiamo la manifattura seriale il
mondo fordista che è rappresentato per
metafore dell'orchestra sinfonica
pensateci un attimo in modo non
pregiudiziale qual caso infatti che un
posto dove sono musicisti anche molto
bravi molto creativi molto capaci di
interpretare in modo soggettivo eppure
l'orchesta funziona soltanto se i
musicisti fanno esattamente quello che
gli impone di fare il direttore quindi
il demiurgo fordista il capo
dell'impresa e quello che in qualche
misura terrena
la capacità creativa dei singoli
musicisti pensandoci così è un po triste
se volete però pensate
tanti luoghi comuni alla fine abbiamo
subito dei quali siamo stati vittima in
questi anni il primo all'efficienza
l'efficienza viene sempre usata viene
detto a tutti sia efficiente per fare i
compiti per lavorare così via però la
finanza non è rapidità l'efficienza
significa usare meno cosa che si può
quindi io vorrei che il mio medico che
il mio magistrato che il mio insegnante
non fossero efficienti ma efficaci cioè
che raggiungessero l'obiettivo come gli
strumenti utili quindi il paradosso
strano e noi idolatriamo l'efficienza
senza capire che è una cosa che ci
sottrarre i valori primo elemento
fondamentale da teheran in conto il
secondo della concorrenza alta paranoia
di questi anni
faccio un esempio molto banale il
curriculum in formato europeo che una
volta non rumenta io cestino quando me
lo mandano perché se fai un curriculum
europeo vuol dire artista e clonando
insieme agli altri cioè che vuoi che io
giudico quello che hai esattamente come
tutti gli altri
non è un caso che poi alla fine ci si
sbizzarrisce con tutte le frasette tipo
cucino faccio sport agonistico amo
viaggiare che una cosa facciamo tutti
non mi dà nessuna data differente magari
è meglio che mi ri fi che regge la
pressione di un bando in scadenza che
lavori sinergicamente con i colleghi
senza fargli lo sgambetto e questo non
puoi dirmelo devi farlo concretamente
allora la concorrenza paradossalmente
non è una preferenza è semplicemente un
dimenticare la nostra unicità per cui
anche questo è un altra piccola bufala
della quale siamo stati vittime ancora
all'eccellenza il termine del premiare
le cose eccellenti anche qui eccellenza
non è qualità l'eccellenza
se tutto il mondo fosse eccellente non
soltanto sarebbe noioso da morire ma
soprattutto non capiremo cosa eccellente
e cosa no amiamo il buon cibo perché di
tanto mangiamo una schifezza
allora forse sarebbe il momento di
essere più normali e dimenticare questo
meccanismo di valutazione di queste
metriche efficienza concorrenza e
eccellenza che in fondo sono le mete di
giudizio che sottraggono valore
sottraggono sangue sottraggono pulsione
e ci fanno diventare tutti i tanti
simpatici robottini e in un mondo di
manifattura seriale è anche conveniente
utile ma forse il mondo
più quello di una volta veramente allora
dove siamo
descriviamo il mondo attuale possiamo
dire che abbiamo tre caratteristiche
molto molto chiare
intanto c'è questa rete globale in cui
si crea si costruisce si produce e si
diffonde la conoscenza è su questo siamo
tutti quanti d'accordo poi c'è una
lingua comune la scimmiottiamo magari a
usiamo imperfettamente però c'è una
lingua di riferimento comune che tutti
quanti adottiamo tranquillamente in più
in questi ultimi anni sta venendo fuori
un uno spazio anche inaspettato molto
molto indefinito per inventare cose
nuove non penso soltanto appunto alla
macchina che si guida da sola o al drone
hanno pensate anche alle strutture
sociali pochi anni fa nessuno aveva
pensato a situazioni come huber con
tutte le critiche che si possono fare
però dei casi in cui anche la vita
sociale si organizza in modo diverso è
questo è il mondo attuale benissimo
cerchiamo di capire come muoverci in
questa mappa cominciano a fare un
esempio locale vediamo che il rapporto a
la città di messina col suo mare quindi
capo peloro
in che modo legge il suo rapporto col
mare dal quale è zero emergono sono
emerse sempre delle forze degli elementi
naturali non conosciuti inaspettati
eppure alla città che cosa fa pensiamoci
in passato 21 guardava la città quindi
di fatto era come se rassicurasse la
città dicendo io vengo dal marzo il dio
del mare ti offro delle opportunità che
sono non soltanto delle bellezze e
quant'altro ma anche ricchezza anche
denaro anche commercio quindi si rivolge
alla città capacità qui è una città
ottocentesca che ha la sua bellissima
palazzata ma dentro c'è un coagulo di
botteghe di commerci di vita di famiglia
dopo il terremoto nettuno si gira di 180
gradi e invece dato le spalle alla città
e cerca di placare il mare quindi il
rapporto psicologico di messina colmare
cambia in modo radicale è in qualche
misura anche difficilmente reversibile
perché comincia ad aver paura del mare
non è un caso che la città attualmente
c'è la guardiamo con un animo appunto un
po laico dalle spalle al mare non ha la
città nel suo reticolo urbano non ha
quasi nessun rapporto con il mare non
c'è permeabilità e questo lo dice
chiaramente mettono placati non ci fai
paura e questo diventa un elemento che
va letto sicuramente quindi in qualche
misura la città sicuramente post
terremoto ha tracciato in modo
rassicurante in modo prevedibile in modo
anche se vogliamo molto statico sia la
gabbia temporale che quella spaziale
spazio tempo sono organizzati in una
griglia
abbiamo la griglia del tempo la figlia
dello spazio messina la molto diversa
prima perché era molto connessa con una
natura che va in continuità dal mare
fino alle colline eppure adesso si è il
reggimento a viviamo questa cosa qui qui
il paradosso non c'è nessuna
contraddizione col resto del mondo
stiamo interpretando in modo più
visibile anche se vogliamo più strano in
un posto così naturalmente ricco come lo
stretto di messina stiamo interpretando
le gabbie spazio temporali che succederà
forse è il momento di domandarselo
sempre cercando di non avere troppi
pregiudizi è vero che c'è un network
globale di conoscenza ma risponde tanto
ai monasteri e la lingua comune il
latino è lo spazio per le invenzioni
imprevedibili sa esattamente quando
inventano il sestante l'astrolabio gli
occhiali quindi siamo in una situazione
che sta riprendendo il discorso del
medioevo dove anche qui siamo stati
abituati a pensare al medioevo con un
periodo oscuro con tutta la caccia alle
streghe eppure c'era però senza senso il
medioevo all'umanesimo il rinascimento
non sarebbero venuti fuori quindi forse
le meteore un posto interessante perché
destrutturato non ha più confini a
connessione i numeri si viaggiava
moltissimo molto più di quanto noi non
immaginiamo allora forse riprendere da
allora il discorso non tornare indietro
per carità ma immaginare che ora ci
viene davanti un mondo imprevedibile in
cui il monastero un oggi si direbbe ad
uno snodo di connessioni di scambi in
cui gli scappati di casa agli artisti
creativi agli intellettuali come diremmo
oggi non delle etichette un po abusate
convergevano senza sapere cosa si
aspettassero però raccontando e
scambiandosi le idee quindi grande
quella fertilizzazione che anche qua è
perfettamente coerente
con la metafora della palin siamo lì e
vediamo cosa viene fuori e questo mi
sembra fondamentale perché è la fonte di
ogni possibile creatività e quindi
dobbiamo reinventare molte altre cose
soprattutto abbiamo da inventare dei
modi che in questo momento possono
costruire il mondo del futuro allora la
metafora del mondo futuro non è più
l'orchestra sinfonica ma il cortile
degli artigiani in cui i valori da
efficienza concorrenza ed eccellenza
diventano esperienza relazioni e
prossimità nel cortile degli artigiani
avvengono delle cose molto banali ma
molto importanti
intanto gli artigiani parlano fra di
loro che significa anche raccontandosi
la propria vita si scambiano un sacco di
idee e quindi si trasmettono il saper
fare
sembra banale ma noi viviamo in un mondo
in cui vi insegnano ci insegnano tutti a
proteggere le idee
però io difendo un principio molto
banale chi protegge l'idea vuol dire che
ha paura di non averne più
quindi generava invece fertilizzata
immunità da sola non vale niente la
chiusa in un cassetto e tirandola fuori
che si interfaccia con le altre idee
crea valore allora gli artigiani senza
che nessuno glielo abbia spiegato e in
un mondo anche 0.0 fanno esattamente
questa cosa qua prendo il caffè insieme
eppure alla fine imparano a migliorare
ciascuno il prodotto che fa orizzontale
in verticale l'artigiano fa un'altra
cosa fichissima che parla con il
committente mentre sta fabbricando la
cosa se la cosa è un vaso un tessuto non
importa ma sicuramente l'artigiano
parlando col committente senza
rendersene conto nemmeno incorpora nel
vaso nell'oggetto la personalità del
committente
quindi il cortile degli artigiani
descrive molto secondo me il mondo in
cui siamo già e saremo necrosi 30 40 200
anni
allora forse il momento di accettare
quest'idea morbida di trasmettere
scambiare le idee siamo esattamente come
i clerici vagantes gli studiosi erranti
non dimentichiamo erranti vuol dire che
vagabondano ma anche che sbagliano
quindi riusciamo a fare un'operazione
molto elementare sapere che ogni passo è
un inciampo corretto all'ultimo momento
quindi accettare lynch pavidità normale
della nostra vita sapendo che tanto alla
fine al massimo crediamo però in questo
modo faremo quello che dici pagante
fingevano di copiare ma di fatto
inventato
le nuove erano super creativi allora la
creatività è questo coraggio fare una
cosa che non sappiamo fare anche che è
inventato la ruota non lo sapeva fare
quindi anche quando ho capito bene che
tutti i protocolli in cui siamo dai
quali siamo avvinghiati l'idea di
appunto a stare nelle scatole nelle
gabbie e così via
servono esattamente a non farci
diventare mai creativi poco o molto non
importano sicuramente avere il coraggio
di fare cose non sappiamo fare
qui c'è un verso un po più o meno nobile
di quelli di valeri e philip dick la
canzone della di mandare ragazzina di de
gregori bufalo bill in cui dice una cosa
estremamente interessante la locomotiva
tra bufale locomotiva la differenza
dagli occhi la locomotiva sarà segnata
il bufalo può scartare di lato e cadere
ora per usarla come metafora la
locomotiva el'innovazione e spostare la
soglia in avanti lungo un sentiero
prevedibile che va bene ci serve
moltissimo ma la creatività è quello che
fa il bufalo non ha una strada davanti e
rischiando di cadere
vadi lato dove non c'è niente è traccia
la strada questo il nostro compito alla
clerici vagantes 2.0 potete metterci i
numeri che volete
sicuramente è ri disegnare la mappa e
questo diventa importante quindi ci
servono a questo punto due elementi
forti che sono lo scardinamento delle
gabbie del tempo e dello spazio spazio
illimitato e tempo indefinito
possiamo farlo se vogliamo sicuramente
sì perché intanto questa è una cosa
molto messinese è possibile essere
resilienti messina è l'unica città del
mondo in cui gli appuntamenti ci danno
come segue quando ci vediamo il tempo
che ci vuole che è una cosa estremamente
rispettosa giudice alle 5 precisa però
il tempo che ci vuole significa
esattamente dammi il tempo di prepararmi
per rispetto nei suoi confronti
arriverò nessuno secca gli appuntamenti
alla fine quindi col dire che comunque
questa cosa funziona magnificamente
possiamo navigare nel tempo e nello
spazio morbidamente rispettandolo ma
senza farcene dominare in gabbie
precotte quindi la tecnica professionale
e fare il morto in acqua
ossia farsi trascinare a galla dal
principio di archimede sforzo 0 fastidio
cene alla corrente si va dove conviene
dove
fortuna andare senza decidere noi in
partenza e soprattutto se ci passa
accanto un oggetto importante lo
affermiamo in un secondo senza fare
nessuno sforzo pensate quanto è potente
questo stato totalmente ricettivo e poi
dentro dal punto di vista come dire
sentimentale psicologico ci fa vedere le
cose in modo molto rilassato e potente
anche in modo pratico perché ci fa agire
seguendo il corrente del seguendo la
corrente e quindi non facendo nessuno
non deformando la realtà
diventeremo interpreti consapevoli molto
lucidi costruttori versatili e visionare
i creativi
faremo quello che vogliamo fare
normalmente ma sapendo che lo stiamo
facendo
quindi la nostra cassetta degli attrezzi
professionali e questa usiamo la pancia
che la sata dell'intuizione non
dell'istinto ma dell'intuizione gli
imprenditori anche nella vulgata degli
economisti sono animati da spiriti
animali hanno l'intuizione vedono
qualcosa che in quel momento nessun
altro stabilendo usando il cuore perché
se non ci innamoriamo dai nostri
progetti e le nostre idee come facciamo
a fare innamorare gli altri quindi è
avere la voglia è anche il tempo di
cesellare sentimentalmente quello che
facciamo quello che vogliamo fare e poi
per il cervello che non è razionale ta
che è una parola anche qua ecologia in
una parola che si usa per le macchine e
la lucidità la consapevolezza per
chiamare le cose esattamente col loro
nome
in questo modo possiamo farcela e
possiamo non soltanto affrontare un
cambiamento radicale ma in qualche
misura anti anticiparlo se vogliamo
disegnarlo noi che mi sembra una bella
cosa
[Applauso]